you're telling me you're worse than
krishan rock at a point in time in your
life you know i feel like she kind of
normal but has the tattoos she you think
she's normal yay really yeah she broke
into his house
cut herself open drew a love letter to
him in blood and then stole his g-wagon
and drove it across the country and was
found in like kentucky like three days
later he really just made it oh my god
google that [__] i swear
that happened and he looked so serious
blueface knows his former artist
christian rock stole his car and is
sharing all the evidence to prove it in
a lengthy series of instagram story
posts on tuesday blueface began to
unravel an array of text messages
between him before she reportedly stole
his g-wagon
she wrote i love blue in blood and then
stole his [__] car
sounds quite normal to me